here we are
oh my gosh she is back my best friend
where we only hang out when we get
monetized
[Music]
it's because you're not you never come
to new york i never come to new york why
is that what what's the deal i am not
good at new york
i love new york that's an excuse figure
it out welcome to yes everything i say
is whitney listen you have money you can
figure it out you can figure out
anything i have money because i don't
live in new york that's why i have it
it's a very simple life hack but what i
will say is with
your financial net worth now
which you guys can google it's probably
not accurate but you can
give it a quick goods
um
good luck getting past all the searches
and people trying to figure out my age
you'll have to scroll down
it's literally those are the most asked
questions like is whitney cummings
secretly 80 or like how much money does
she have
how much plastic surgery does she have
oh my god yeah it's like it's always and
then net worth is in there somewhere
okay yes i don't have any money left i
spent all plastic surgery correct
but you could get a super cute like
little brown stone but if you have a lot
of money why does it have to be super
cute
because your money doesn't go very far
what you wanted to you want to have an
estate in new york i just you want to
live next to
in jersey you want to be able to
cohabitate with someone yes walk to one
side of the room and fart
and then the other side of the room and
they'll not know listen you need to be
able to fart within a 12 by 12 room you
can't do it with
quarantine was literally just butt jazz
from me
to him and him back to me
it was you know that's what we did i
can't i just we have different diets i
don't know what to tell you look at me
i've got all the shit that i eat i can't
create my farts are just too gnarly for
new york yeah uh cohabitation i only
have you for an hour and a half just
trying to really get through this new
york small talk thing so you can get
your special in your books i'm sorry i
thought we were catching up we no we
cannot catch up we have to do that
another time we all we only hang out in
like six hour block increments we
realize that
we our friendship is like so stressful
because well we first of all you're my
favorite person to be friends with on
different coasts because all we do is
send ugly um
we do we don't not how are you how's it
going we don't need to do that our
relationship is so above checking in or
knowing any logistics about each other
like i don't know where you're from but
i do
yeah it's just her sending me this we
talk about look i swear it's consensual
i swear
we just send each other hideous clothes
from our favorite website shop
who if you guys want to give us some
credits we will keep this publicly going
we just send each other we have the same
like wake up and online shop schedule it
seems like
and the game is can i find the new ugly
thing on shop bopper net a porter before
she gets to it and sometimes you'll send
it i'm like ah she got it first
and we're just like making each other
laugh and it's like just silly and done
yeah and then when we see each other
it's like we need to start a business
yeah we just get deep into like who's
your lawyer how much commission are you
paying because you got to make sure you
write this off like we just
there's so little time yeah but i do
like that when we hang out
it's uh we're able to just like get into
like
weird conversations yeah about money be
funny be silly i love it i miss you yeah
i miss you and i love you and i feel
like you're one of the few friends that
uh over the pandemic i still was able to
stay close to even though we felt very
far away yeah you know i think everyone
was like struggling and just being like
i can only talk to like two people a
week i also feel like you went to the
next level with your social media
presence during the pandemic maybe it's
because you were just trying to avoid
this toxic relationship of this man that
just has to go everywhere with you he's
so cute
but you like really like leaned and i
feel like i leaned into social media in
a way where people just thought i was
like losing my mind yeah and like on
crack or something
but
you really like leaned into it and i
feel like your voice just
i don't know i just felt like it's one
of the few social media engagements
where i really feel like i'm
getting closer to you without
it feeling
great corny does that make sense i hired
a social media team i was like
i'm like i really never want to post
other than like thirsty thursdays where
i write about hotmail celebs that's the
only thing where i'm like excited to do
everything else i'm like i don't care it
kills me so we schedule the post and
they put them up and sometimes people
would be like oh you look so cute this
thing that you post on instagram today i
was like i posted something on instagram
cool
i truly am so detached that's so small
so do you just send them the copy or
send them what so we'll like go over
like okay we gotta like promote the book
and the special like blah blah blah and
then we just they schedule it out and
then like they write
like sort of like the more like general
captions where it's just like flashback
friday they can like write that but like
anything else like i'll just like
because your voice is so specific yeah
like yeah yeah
like way you say things yeah it feels so
personal yeah i just are you catfishing
me i feel catfished no i'm so listened
invested in your social media who am i
in love with you too you can find a
white woman named
white woman emily emily keeps me alive
they're all named emily
emily
[Applause]
emma emily
it's so true and they will make sure you
schedule like they post for you yeah
yeah
but i don't want to be like i maybe i'm
a luddite or whatever but i just i'm so
like i can't i just want to like create
fun stuff i don't want to have to like
post on social media and like think
about it so they take all that off but
it is such a necessary part of what like
we do now to stay engaged i want to be
off social media in five years that's my
goal wow yeah it probably will happen
that's kind of brilliant i'll probably
have some other job but like you need to
be on instagram but you know well let me
ask you okay so i just i by the way i'm
jumping around and this is gonna feel
very inorganic because i do not have a
lot of time with phoebe uh she has
actual real boundaries and she's one of
the few people i respect enough to honor
them so she will get out uh at her time
um just watch your special
dying
really dying wait are you being honest
why i haven't i would not bring it up
otherwise okay
play back some of the other podcasts i
just don't bring it up because i cannot
lie
and i was dying laughing it was just
such a like
um i never say this because look we've
all seen everything you know what i'm
saying we've all seen every version of
every joke or seen it covered in some
way even if it wasn't a special i'm at
the coming store every night like yeah
it was just relentlessly
breath of fresh air like it was one of
the few specials i think i've ever seen
right i feel like i got to be a comedy
fan oh i wasn't like i have something
like that or i've heard something like
that i just got to like enjoy it and i
want to get straight into uh the
circumcision stuff because
i am jealous of you because i have been
trying to talk about that for so long
and i just couldn't crack it or i
couldn't figure it out and you just like
nailed it
and um
sorry your man is here yeah he's hey
babe
you went because it's the kind of
premise where once a comedian does it no
one else can do it oh really i'm saying
it's been done and you did it so
thoroughly and so profoundly and so
elegantly because when i was trying to
do something the fact that we don't talk
about how damaging circumcision is to
the male psyche is crazy okay that's why
they're mad
they say that hold on i have a whole
document of when i tried to write about
circumcision and i couldn't figure it
out
okay
so
i did some reading about it psychiat
some psychiatrists think that all the
shame stuff starts with circumcision
um and
i got into what i was trying to talk
about at some point well that's a
religious thing so you're being
anti-semitic i'm like no
it's not only jewish people to do it you
know it's not something that's just like
this thing we don't even ask about uh uh
but men who are circumcised are 60 more
likely to have difficulty identifying
and expressing their feelings
wow because think about it your first
experience is with the woman
is your mother handing you over to some
guy yeah right having some horrible
trauma happen and then everybody claps
yeah and the excuses you said it you
just it drove me nuts because it was
just like the perfect bit
and uh when you said like it's about
cleanliness yeah i'm like guys you can
wash a dick well you can how hard is it
to like just wash a baby's dick it's
just like a little thin ball yeah just
roll it back just like
yeah so bae will do a demonstration
video you'll post it on youtube and be
like step one
but i just feel like guys should use it
as a defense in their behavior more like
i hate to give you guys more legs to
stand up but the fact that someone's
like why are you mad it's like because
when i was
two days old my mom had my dick chopped
off yeah like of course i'm a little bit
mad at women my dick tips courts i don't
trust you yeah and i guess it takes some
of the sensation yes when you get
circumcised yeah so you want to you want
to keep the whole package was that a
tricky uh thing to talk about were you
okay with this coming up in the special
absolutely fine actually he's so cute
he's like it pays the bills it's fine
i'm so obsessed with y'all's
relationship do you have any like the
last two years your career has like gone
to another level another level
thanks you're welcome i feel like it
thank you for not arguing with me on
that okay there's no way i was about to
show on freeform picked up never
happened new book out right now
uh
new special out sorry harry tubman you
have your own imprint books tidy
reparations has any of this affected
your relationship at all
no he
i don't say he doesn't care but he's
worked in music for
15 years and so he's sort of like seen
it all done it all traveled the world so
like he understands like that stuff is
cool but it's like not
like it's not that it's not really me
but you know what i mean like there's
just
there's more to me than just the career
stuff so he's just sort of like that's
great keep working hard but it's never
like
what i'm threatened by like he just
doesn't care in that way i think what
was the um experience um shooting the
pilot for the freeform pilot we shot it
in la um but the show's gonna be set in
new york so we're gonna shoot everything
else in new york which i'm really
excited about oh that's cool it was sort
of like i've never been number one on
the call sheet before so i took that
like responsibility like so
hugely like i was like this is very
important like so i'm like i ha i'm
never on time for stuff he can attest to
this um and so i was like i have to burp
sorry
oh that's actually fine
emily has some oh my god
[Laughter]
emily emily has some kind of acid reflux
situation
she's been burping for two days we had
to send her home yesterday
look she could not stop burping it was
so disgusting
okay so what are your symptoms is my
face quicker okay my stomach
emily's dying
my stomach feels like it's burning like
burning and churning i'm have you ever
felt this before
no oh
no would you eat for dinner
spaghetti squash
but i already googled that you can't get
you can eat spaghetti sauce roasting me
out with the burping i think a lot
sorry
it's like we're in a fraternity now i've
never seen anything like this
burp wise
oh my
god does it burp like a mountain
oh my god
i ain't a new co-worker
for this this is harassment i'm ill
you can't burp all through this
interview later you just stop burping i
hate burping i can't help it
it's like
i'd rather you shit
i'm not a fan of it
is anyone willing to pay emily for this
content if it's sent uh privately
so that she can go to a doctor i need to
go to a doctor so bad like
what is it acid reflux or gerds it's uh
called girts you have gerds i believe
that's what the internet thinks benton
has it also wait what's gerds
it's when you produce too much acid
benton right in your uh stomach so you
just it's hard you have to produce more
acid to digest something
i need a good juicy one like this hey
guys i quit
i quit
so little i need like a uh no
if you
i'm so jealous
she by the way was doing it so much i
got nauseous and i was like if you
better forget i'm gonna puke
because if if people puke in front of me
i start puking i have that contagious
thing
like you know when you know you're about
to puke i swear to god if i fucking puke
on these new microphones because you
won't stop burping i swear to god
emily white emily's have to make it all
the time oh
well
i swear she's classy she's a writer
three books written her third book it's
incredibly sophisticated and so she
snorts she burps she's america's
sweetheart she's about to be all over
your screens computers um give her a
shot
even though she is not she is really
just relentlessly authentic if you've
not learned anything uh here today i
keep it real
okay but also
the authority on all things trash so the
authority on all things trash she let me
know when i was curling my hair before
we started she let me know that was a
trash behavior
and i i nothing i value more in life
than someone that's just like you're
being a trash person do you think that
gayle king before she sat down to
interview barack obama was curling her
motherfucking wig do you think she was
like hey barry sorry
if i was interviewing mama i'd be doing
my hair up until the last second yes i
would just be there is every second i
would take that opportunity to improve
my hair yes
in fact i'd be oiling my legs yes
i bet he just thinks women do her all
the time because they're constantly like
primping for him
but on uh the last time i shot a special
i called you we talked about this last
time you're in the podcast yes
in dc i wanted to come to it but i think
i couldn't because of work yes yes yeah
yeah you were doing two dope queens or
whatever
one of your things yeah and um i uh i
called you because i was like
i was like this is the person
who is gonna give me the answer that i'm
actually gonna trust uh and i'm not just
calling for a confirmation bias i'm not
just calling for to get like this is
okay right yeah and i called you and i
think i said
i said something that was like off the
reservation or something and i was like
can i say this you're like no
i'm like maybe don't commit it to
phil maybe not i was like but it's like
off the reservation like i couldn't even
talk you're like no it's just no no
thanks yeah is this um a book how is
this um
different from the last couple in terms
of how you've grown
and how do you know when a book is done
i think i'm a better writer i think this
is my best book that i've written um
and i think part of it is just because i
balance
like i think the book has a lot of funny
stuff like i write about bake off but
then i also write about serious stuff
like performance of allyship and
and our choice to like not have kids and
how you know women who
choose to be child free can really get
judged a lot of society so i just really
wanted to have a good mix of like funny
stuff but also things i was thinking
about cooped up because i feel like
everybody
inside
for 15 months your mind is just you're
going over your life you're going over
your choices
you're trying to figure out like what
you want to do with like the next couple
years of your life so i think it was
just sort of
i was really reflective with this book
and i think that's different than the
other two yeah like still is funny but
also just like deeper and more pathos
yeah and then so in terms of the the
decision to not have kids it's so
interesting because the one thing i the
only thing that as someone that is
childless the one thing that annoys me
is like don't you find that all i feel
like everyone that should be having kids
isn't yeah do you know what i'm saying
like if someone's like i don't think we
should have kids i just don't think it's
right i mean the environment's falling
apart i don't want to bring a kid into
this environment you're like but you're
the exact person that should have kids
you know what i'm saying all the morons
that are like yeah i'm the best let's
just have 12 ch that's who's ruining the
world so the irony is all my smartest
coolest friends are the ones that are
not having kids should i
should bake off should we just go for it
just like i mean who's gonna fix the
the ignorant people keep breeding like
crazy and then all the smart cool people
are like i just don't think it's a good
idea right now like i could be i could
birth an activist oh no that's what i'm
saying i feel like the people that are
gonna change the world are coming from
couples that are choosing to be
childless which is fine you can't you
know martyr yourself but but um yeah my
friend nikki my best friend from college
she's her thing is like she's like i
just don't want to bring a kid into this
world there's going to be like no water
in 20 years and i'm like well there's
gonna be no water unless you have a kid
because your kid is the one that would
solve this problem yeah that's gonna fix
it but it's gonna fix it all she's gonna
handle it yeah she's like i'm not gonna
go to the met gala i'm actually gonna
work not doing this unless the other
people are like i'm an activist i went
to the met gala i'm like you just wanted
to hang out with j-lo like it's not
and i don't blame you
yeah but don't also don't say that
you're an activist don't do well i do
think you know there's a lot of
i saw over the pandemic it was hard to
watch a lot of people
that were feeling irrelevant or their
shows were shut down and that was kind
of their way of getting like some
attention yeah that was the performative
activism it was too much it's like hey
guys what did you donate just where'd
you donate you have a donate and you
don't need to say anything yeah or
retweet someone else who knows what
they're talking about or
just read a book and then like don't
post a picture about rob and d'angelo
like just re read the book i know i'm
gonna post the white
house hey guys just checking in this
book is i was like
i don't want your check-in
i really i reject this check-in well the
best is when like people were posting uh
uh sort of um me and white supremacy
like maya's book like excerpts of it on
their social and don't post it yeah
people buy the book yeah stop posting
the book for free so people can read it
for free yes give them the link so they
can purchase her work stop putting her
work on your instagram without paying
for it you're like
i know everyone's fucking garbage yeah
well so
i'm so sick of it
truly it's a lot it's it's too much it's
exhausting
it's exhausting but let me ask you last
time um
uh we were hanging out or not it was
like a couple times ago you said
something that was really fascinating to
me and i've thought about a lot and you
are now like running a company like you
have a production company now you have a
book imprint and i remember we were
talking about something when you were
pitching a show where you were like yeah
i have to basically walk this line where
i can't have too strong of an opinion or
draw two stronger boundaries or else
i'll uh come off like an angry black
woman yeah
and i was just thinking about that i
think now i just like don't care and now
you're just like too rich and famous
because that's successful not to no i'm
not too rich i looked up my net worth
the other day because i was like all
right let me just see and someone said
14 million can i tell you something tim
dillon was just over tim dillon was just
here yeah uh and i was like oh phoebe
robinson is coming after he's like she's
really rich right no
welcome to my life everybody thinking i
have all this fucking money yeah i might
no but listen bitch
listen bitch
let's not we are not the same okay you
and michael passion king have
motherfucking money
okay you walk me through your goddamn
renovation of your compounds
okay
and i'm like i'm like
i have to get someone to come take care
of the tree now i have no money left
okay but someone says i'm worth 14
million could not be farther from the
truth 14 million i see that but
sometimes it's owner do you if you own a
place or like all your assets all my
assets are still nowhere near that right
but could this be the amount you earned
before you paid off a bunch of people
whitney i appreciate your belief it does
say 14. your net worth is probably i'm
going to say the internet is going to
say you're worth 150.
that's
150. but i also paid for they don't take
into account your the expenses you paid
i put two people through rehab my mom
had a stroke without health insurance
cedars cyanide has most of my money what
you're you're the internet says you're a
net worth it's the same as khloe
kardashian what no it says mine is worth
30 million if you look at this no
i think it's more than that
is this why everyone's so mean to me now
yes
bitch yes
okay i hadn't looked this up okay no
wonder winnie coming says not even 40
and her net worth is already insane
this is not true by the way no wonder
everyone's such an asshole yeah
oh
people hear the show goes in the
syndication yeah yeah yeah
i bought a house guys you were like oh
this bitch is rich it says estimated to
be 30 million i don't see whatever you
see but there was that article that came
out said i was gonna get 40 million or
something like that it's all it's all
it's gone yeah it's been spent i pay for
managers that are suing me oh no you got
lawsuits all kinds of nightmares yeah i
don't have that yet
uh yeah it's it really is you do start
to break even yeah the more money people
think you have the more they start just
suing you and then you have no money you
know what i'm saying so it's like just
the amount of people that uh tried to
sue me saying that i stole their idea
for uh nbc's whitney
uh
like that cost me like a million dollars
just to like not have to go to court to
say like oh you wrote the show about my
life i stole that idea from you like
okay
yeah it's just like kind of
wild yeah it's it's i i do i have
started investing though last time we
talked about i have started investing in
things so it's like i have less cash but
it's in
investments
and in a 401k yeah yeah i also don't pay
taxes is that weird
um
that you know it'll save you a lot of
money
just don't pay taxes
honestly that's how so many of these
celebs have fucking money
they don't pay taxes that's what i'm
saying i'm like jlo let me see your
fucking receipts this is to make a lot
of sense because people do joke a lot
that i like have all this money and i
feel like it's this weird elephant in
the living room cause i'm like if you
guys only knew in the living room what's
that the elephant in the living room i
just bought an elephant for the living
room
it's just this new i'm not that rich you
guys it's just i remember when i was a
broke ass comic and i saw that
vulture.com article talking about how
much you were pocketing from the
syndication i was like damn this bitches
that's not how it really works i'm i'm
just if i had that much money
no offense i love you
i would not be doing this
i would go you know what i i called it
on the podcast that was really fun hobby
but meet me in turks and caicos and
let's hang out i'll fly you out this is
not how we'd be hanging out if i had the
amount of money you think like no
offense i love doing this but i wouldn't
be doing this if i had that kind of
money here's the thing to me money does
buy happiness if you anyone that's like
money doesn't buy you happiness that
means you grew up with money if you grew
up without it and you get it i'm like
the ability to say no i'm not gonna go
do that casino you know outside tulsa
with nine connections whatever like yeah
being able to say no to things to me
that is true happiness and that's what
money affords you you know so for me i
don't want things i just want money
because that feels like freedom if
someone needs something like i can cover
it if someone because to me i save money
for emergencies because i've had so many
weird like curveballs in life yeah i
always assume i'm gonna have to like
write a crazy check for like a hospital
bill or like some drama or dental thing
yeah my mom's in a nursing home and she
has like all these crazy like to get her
teeth repaired like get up new ones it's
like 30 000
to get new teeth to get a whole new set
of teeth wow
last person i got a new set of teeth
they weren't done being bulimic yet so
that was a waste of money
you just out here buy people teeth do
you not understand why people think
you're fucking rich bitch are you
fucking serious i don't i don't know why
people think i have money so i bought
this person full set of fucking team
like bit what not like a birkin bag you
buying teeth that is some fucking
generational wealth
shit
this is not generation this is not
inherited money this is new money i i do
not get to keep
it comes in and it goes right out and it
keeps i guess it keeps me motivated like
when people are like yeah i just give
away all my money so that i stay
motivated i'm like i don't need to do
that who says that elon musk i guess did
that he lex friedman they gave away all
their stuff just so that they wouldn't
be complacent
okay it's a thing yeah yeah it's like uh
it's like i know i'll be fine even if i
give away all my money type that yeah
that's what is that okay you're making
money okay i'm not going to let you do
this to me you're fine you
you live in new york yeah that's why you
don't if you lived here you would have
as much money as me
okay it's literally my overhead it's
just like you're paying as much in rent
as my mortgage
yeah
let's
yeah that's the thing but i i i would
love to live in new york i just haven't
figured out the way to do it that feels
like it's like a deal that i can
accept money-wise do it and we'll do
we'll do stand-up shows together we'll
bop around the city and you know what i
can't deal with the horse carriage thing
either that really stresses me out yeah
that's really sad yeah it's just like
it's just like a bummer you know what
i'm saying no i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
do it but i just feel like i need like
space with animals i have like big
animals
why don't you just text chris rock and
ask him what neighborhood he lives in
a house out there bring your dog bring
what's your what's your horse's name
duke sure
[Music]
i feel like every black person thinks
white people's horses every white woman
is named emily and their horses are
named dude
you know what like yes
yes i
i feel like you conflated my dog who
looks a little bit like marmaduke
in duke the whore like i feel like all
my animals just came together yes yes
yes and then red like rent a house in
jersey for three months do a shit ton of
shows you think they have like epstein
money the way you're talking to me
you think i can like transport a horse
to the other side of the country
i don't know how much does it cost you i
think i'm like a cartoon villain
you think i'm just like
i mean like what like you think i'm like
running house of darion
i'm just saying i don't have the kind of
money you think i have but it's kind of
funny i that you believe leave duke here
yeah duke can stay here duke can date
with one of my many house managers
uh i'll just have uh
wait you have a house man no i'm joking
i was gonna be like bitch
no i think here's the thing house
manager is basically just a husband
that you pay so i just need to get a
husband so that i have a free house
manager that's kind of the goal or like
some kind of partner yeah yeah that's
what they do yeah it's like house
managers just to like manage all the
like the people i know that have house
managers like they never have like a
light bulb out oh
it must be nice someone like gets ahead
of it oh that's cool if i have a light
bulb out it's like benton can you come
with me with the light bulb bented was
you benton was not as you were doing
every job basically for a while there
house manager assistant
makeup artist yes i was
i've never seen him get any teeth
[Applause]
this is the teeth i was born with two of
them are still baby teeth okay well
we're okay well
okay i've never seen benton laugh so
hard during an interview this is so
funny
and it says like except by the time
you're 50 it'll be like 250 million
dollars that's what we all read that i
read reading and i was like this is not
my vision jimmy fallon read it
wanda sykes reddit
are you are you just naming the people
on the tech chain where you all just
trash me
and like what if it's someone until
calling you rich is trashing you you're
like these fucking motherfuckers i love
the idea that you people like screen
grab my instagram like that's what
you're going to wear 250 million in the
bank and you're wearing that fucking
t-shirt on your phone like i feel like
that's how people say make fun of me if
i wasn't me
like i would hate a person if i
had read that article but yeah
michael probably has that kind of money
i do not have that kind of money to be
very clear you will see me at the
buffalo run casino next week in tulsa
oklahoma i will be in the des moines
iowa uh casino next wednesday for
charities i'm doing comedy at casinos on
wednesday yeah so
just to be very clear to stay humble
yeah i mean two two really pay off these
you saw the vases downstairs um those
are not from cost plus worldwide yet
no one will know the difference uh
but yeah it's weird i mean taxes are a
lot i also i was just talking to tim
about this i am very uh who's tim tim
dillon oh okay he's just
tim oh my gosh
that we're all supposed to he takes care
of duke
he's duke's um hairstylist he's duke's
acupuncture guy
i do not spend a lot of money so
i do not spend a lot of money so we've
we talked about this last time we were
on because we like dig right into money
every time i now know why because you
think i have so much
i will tell you i can confirm whitney
does not spend money anywhere but the
vet
that's right the only place she makes it
rain is the best that's right
and i'll pay for other people's yeah if
she goes into the event and you it is
like it's like a scene in the movie the
door is open she's like
on me you get a knee and you get a knee
i did get one of my aunt's new knees and
a new car and the knees were more
expensive but she got locked in the new
car
four days after the surgery and got
stuck in the car for a couple days and
it messed up the knees you know just got
the knees redone they had to get all
they got all infected because she
couldn't get out of the car damn girl
yeah
when you're buying a second pair of
knees for the same person that's when
things get a little a little frustrating
when it's like another set of knees on
the same person
that's when when shit really hits the
van but i don't spend my like i don't
have i'm actually actually really
prenurious like i hotels what was that
word
okay
that's the other housekeeper
i hate all of you i am not airing this i
am not gonna for someone that is on
their third book has a special out he's
about to have a show on freeform her own
production company and an imprint i will
not i will not doesn't need to air this
okay okay i will not
you no one is gonna be you are going to
be so much richer than me so soon
cool
i would love for that to happen great
i'm not going to argue with that we now
stop the conversation
real quick of me
and phoebe robinson from two dope queens
now she's with me and we're just two
dope fiends
[Laughter]
but thanks thanks to better help we can
get some addiction treatment look
i think if
we exude anything on this podcast it's
mental health
tip top shape
we like to discuss mental health we are
i think the key
honestly here's what happens i think if
you talk a lot about mental health
struggles or are really
you know adamant about discussing sticky
things people assume you're crazy but
the craziest thing to do is to keep it
inside and not talk about it i do
remember one time i i did go to a
therapist this is why you have to go to
better help you guys there's a lot of
kooks out there and uh
knows how to vet the kooks
and uh i went to a therapist once who
was like
you know i think we really need to dig
into
the trauma of you being born
i was like what he was like when you
come out
of the vaginal cavity
it's so cold and the way the doctor
pulls you out and if it's like a certain
temperature in the room it's really
traumatic and i'm like you said how do
you know my uh my therapist told me not
my better health therapist one of my
whacks told me that um she could tell by
my personality that i was very loved as
a baby like as an infant i was very
loved but then once i started talking is
when i was started to get
oh she read you didn't she
she said so the problem is you yeah your
personality that's really messed up
pulled away from you and all of this
started and i was like when i started
speaking i had a personality yeah
yeah
everybody remember the therapist that i
went to that one time that told me i
should only eat diet bread that was
from sarah lee company i shall
what does it have to do with
me being depressed better help is a
better option better help is a better
option and this podcast is sponsored by
better help and good for you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com whitney there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available in many areas
and this service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor hey emily yeah
you have a band-aid on your neck i know
let me guess
hickey try
trying to hang yourself
no that's a vampire box oh that's the
best halloween season
tried to hang yourself but didn't want
to ruin your favorite kate spade scarf
oh god
[Laughter]
so good
uh no i uh would you believe it's a
hickey if i told you actually it was a
hickey i'd be wearing it loud and proud
with a little person yeah who the heck
you would draw a heart around i would
i'd be like my husband this is a curling
iron burn but it's such a um why isn't
your hair curly
we know it's not a hickey because you
haven't taken an uber in a while you
know why my hair's not curly because we
were supposed to be here at
10 and so i woke up curled my hair and
then we weren't you have to be here till
1 30. so i went back to bed that's weird
because we all were here at 10. so
it's strange strange that we were all
here at tim with our solids
i thought we were told 130. look
grove can't help with a healthy mind but
it can help with a healthy everything
else it is an online marketplace that
delivers healthy home beauty and
personal care products just directly to
your door i don't know why i just said
just i just got a little bit confused
because i was so excited about
presenting emily with these tan bamboo
hyper allergenic eco badges it so she
could take that weird piece of uh flesh
love like what is that it looks like
steel wool i don't know what that is
yeah don't go in the sun cover yourself
in these tan
it's like a latex like oh gosh get away
from us
the band-aids that the grove sent me and
my little pet are so much cuter they're
eco-friendly put that on your head yeah
those looks
and then you might get a hickey grove
takes the guesswork out of going green
every product is guaranteed to be
good for you
your family and the planets are the
creams or the tissues from growth
because a lot of times by the way i
think that yeah these are from growth
this is a good tissue this is going to
sound weird but well that is a good
tissue it really is an asmr with growth
tissue this is my favorite place to put
it are you stuffing your bra no i put
them in my armpits i do that too
oh this is my asmr this is a good stop
talking during the asmr sorry
join over two million households who
choose to shop sustainably at groves
by the way could i have i could probably
do that yeah here plus no
plus shipping is fast and free on your
first order choosing products that are
better for you and the planet has never
been easier for a limited time when
listeners go to grove.com whitney you
will get to choose a free starter set
with your first order and we'll send you
whitney's snotty tissue
look at this go to grove.com we need to
get your exclusive offer that's
grove.com whitney grove we love you
back to
pepe
i don't do this fake industry standard
where i give agents managers and lawyers
just across the board everybody makes
something business managers don't get a
percentage like i i'm really like stingy
about not paying
everybody on everything which is a big
thing that and i don't this is all
independent and no one commissions this
podcast that's great so that's where you
get killed as people work so hard and
then but having these uncomfortable
conversations of like hey like you know
will smith doesn't pay 10 to his agent
manager he like negotiates it down tom
cruise they're like i'll give you three
percent i'm not gonna give you
everything so the people that have the
most money i think are the ones that say
that don't spend it
you know wow like when i first made
money i uh the first year i bought a
house and i didn't know how taxes worked
and i was
eighty thousand dollars in debt because
i didn't know how to pay taxes so it was
like i was just like an idiot yeah about
it so now it's like really i think more
about not spending it okay i don't buy i
i literally only go on websites to find
funny clothes to send you
i'm rich in my friendships yeah what
have you been spending money on
uh
bae and i are moving into a new
apartment that's bigger um and so we're
just buying furniture mm-hmm
but you can get so much of that uh
like paid partnership stuff i don't want
to do that see i don't want to be like
hey guys thanks so
much want to know where you got it no
don't i don't want you to know where i
buy my furniture mind your fucking
business okay boundaries
like i i just feel like paid
partnerships are too much like just
listen you find your couch where you
find your house
you don't have to pay for a couch i i
will pay for privacy okay so that is
rich
no that's the right that is the i don't
pay full price for couches
okay oh i sat on a toilet and posted a
photo of it to get a deal on it
i mean that's i'm not that's why i'm
trash
i'm really not gonna rosa parks did not
stay in her seat
so i can have my butt cheeks out to get
a free toilet she did not do i know i
know she did not do it for this is
paying full price yes paying the ticket
price
okay you know you've made it when you're
paying for the same price everyone else
pays okay got it got i got it you're not
i'm not like you're not hassling
companies yeah no it's just like
honestly i do feel like
i am and the thing i'm most excited
about is just like having this you know
as a stand-up like you just want to have
the special on hbo like it just did i
don't care how old you are when you
start doing comedy that is like the
thing so the fact that i have an hbo max
i feel like
i did it i made it so i hope people
watch me i'm like i can forever say that
i have a santa special on hbo max and
that's funny no one can take that away
from you
do you want a tour do you like touring
i like touring when bae
is the tour manager because then we can
like hang out and spend time together um
i was gonna try and tour next year but
now with the freeform show i really have
to make sure i do a good job so we will
get a second season so i'm just like i'm
not gonna do stand up
and then
probably 20 23 i'll like pick back up
and like do like a mini tour right right
yeah and then you can do it like yeah
after your show and yeah yeah yeah you
know help promote it let me ask you so
um on the show was there everyone wants
to talk about how like
you can't say anything more and you
can't joke
was there any moments on your show where
you're like ugh let's just not put this
in the pilot i don't want to push it
like how
no you feel like there was any network
notes any
from coming from podcasts and doing
stand up and be able to say whatever you
want was there anything you felt like
you had to compromise on i mean sure
like you know the network wants to be
happy and they know their audience more
than i know their audience but for me i
always feel like
it's usually just like
straight male comedians complaining
being like oh god saying anything
anymore
they're the only ones who are
complaining by the way they're the only
ones it is so true and they're like i
can't say tranny anymore and you're like
you didn't even have a joke about it
yeah you're you're you're annoyed of
words being taken away from you that you
never used in the first place you're
like you've talked for so long how do
you have anything left to say yes
[Applause]
it's so true you're trying to silence me
no one's heard of you yeah no one's
we're muting you because you're annoying
not cause you're offensive they're
shadow banning me
are they like
they don't know you it's so ignorant and
even like these big time guys i'm not
gonna like name any names but i'm just
sort of like
you're fine yes you're fine it's it's so
funny to me how the melodramatic and uh
everyone's so sensitive now no you're
sensitive they're the most sensitive
you're the big baby who's like i can't
say this word that i never have said
anyway i mean i was um
it's also who's they like it's like it's
funny or it's not you can say whatever
you want if you have a clever joke like
i was uh at the comic store this was
before the pandemic and there was a
comedian that is not super famous but it
was doing a bit about fat chicks
and it was just like it was just bombing
no no one from a vulture.com no
journalist no twitter feud no one was
trying to cancel him people just weren't
involuntary laughing yeah it was just
that simple and it was okay i can't make
that tricks jokes like
it's just the our problem is not the fat
chicks part it's the joke part there's
no jokes it's just not funny so it's not
it's it's not like a couple people on
twitter that are trying to come get you
because of their self-righteous
indignation and like liberal beliefs
it's just you're bombing dude it's not
that what was funny 40 years it's just
not funny anymore and a woman in the
audience just went can you stop
and i was like dude that's that's it i
would i i would be pissed at someone
telling me to stop i would like just i'm
gonna leave just you fucking well the
same comedian was in nashville doing
that same joke and the same thing
happened that's this lady was crazy
you're fat
it's true yeah it is true
that's amazing i just feel like i think
like people were like we don't have to
listen to this yeah and i think now like
you can mute people you can unfollow
people so i think the same going like
can we just stop this when it's
happening it's annoying but also as an
audience member i would i would probably
just be like i'm paying for this yeah
and cancel culture these guys aren't
canceled they're all in cancelled
culture and they win emmys i'm like
who gets cancelled on wins is a fucking
statue yeah what does that even mean i'm
like it helps them you get more money
yes it's it's you kevin hart has more
money now who gets cancelled and wins a
statue every general in the south
it really is it's now a way to make
yourself the underdog
i'm like what and then people think
you're like brave because you said that
that ignorant thing 20 years ago you
know what i'm saying yeah and then more
people are gonna go watch it
and
and i think nonsense yeah it's it's
really also this fake level of bravery
like i'm gonna say the thing no one can
say like it's not brave it's kind of
just like cheap but yeah you know so
maybe there's a reason why no one has
said it because it's fucking stupid
i'm going out on a limb folks like yeah
totally it's like cool the
the goal isn't to upset people the goal
is to make people laugh that's the
edgiest thing you can do like you know
what this isn't funny this is funny fine
i'm gonna just say the thing that's
funny yeah and get out of here the idea
that like it's a bravery contest now of
who's gonna say the most problematic
thing it's like it's like an ignorance
contest like who's gonna be the most
ignorant because that means they're
brave it's just like
it's so wild yeah and it's also not real
you go on the road and it's like every
bumper sticker is still like
you know
some racist sexist if you can read this
the bitch fell off you're like everybody
misogyny and racism is alive and well
guys don't worry don't worry like you're
good yeah yeah yeah i mean it's just
such a um
yeah that you can't say anything anymore
thing is is so funny to me and also the
complaint is also ridiculous because the
more things that are off limits the more
the funnier we get so even if that is
true you should be grateful because the
more stuff that's taboo the more
dangerous spaces to sort of plan you
just have to level up and like not be
cheap anymore yeah learn like learn how
to write jokes
the end
period you know learn how to write a
funny joke and you'll be fine but was
there anything like in that and because
my network experience being a little bit
you know was was further along ago where
i just felt like whether it's like
companies owned by disney or not even
about like twitter democracy or stuff
like that was there anything that was
like let's choose our battles and we'll
just do this later i think
language was a thing because you know i
just sort of write the way that people
talk so there's a lot of curse words so
we had to pair a lot of that down and
then there was like a a plan b thing
that we sort of touched on they were
like we don't know
if you can say
plan b and i was just like well i don't
think people were walking around being
like emergency contraceptive like that's
not right right now anyone's talking so
we had like back and forth about that
and we worked it out what can you called
tiny abortion yeah
mini like
tania boba yeah yeah
but they were they've actually were
really good like i think
i think if you're going to work with me
you kind of know what you're going to
get you don't mean like and i also think
that that you know there's an
opportunity to sometimes be more
creative like when you can't say the
thing it's like okay this is an
opportunity to sort of be more creative
and you get you get a joke out of it
because you find a funny way to
understand so it's fine 100 you know
just like leaning hard into that yeah so
when you start shooting i haven't hired
a room yet we're we're in the process of
hiring a room we're going to start
shooting next spring yeah and just i
just can't believe it's happening i'm
just like oh my god this is going to be
like so much work but i'm really excited
because i'm like i'm going to learn a
whole like new set of skills i didn't
have before so i'm just sort of like
okay
and how is the hiring process going it's
good i mean we're just reading like a
bunch of i have to burp again
you're reading excuse me
hi emily
he is so in love with you he's just
looking at you
like just he has a half job right now
he's suspect with you
and uncircumcised
you two are just so what's the last time
you fought about something
oh the reality remember india
dragging him to india to go see the man
you're really in love with he loved he
loved going to india to see bono but
just really quick the fact that phoebe
robinson is basically dating bono
and
has also someone that loves her so much
and just puts up with the fact that bono
kind of is like it's kind of being
requited
he was like phoebe has to be in india
for this show like forever but wasn't it
his birthday or your birthday it was his
birthday you're like can we go see my
crush in india on your birthday and he
said yes you want to go get diarrhea and
watch me flirt with
bono for your birthday what a nightmare
for babe um but it was when he because
he was on the road um for like 10 weeks
with a rock band and then like we just
like weren't talking as much and so we
had like a fight about like how we just
like weren't
talking as much so the fight was i don't
we don't get to see we love each other
so much and we're not taught what a
nightmare
those are your fights i miss you and
let's talk more yeah
nothing in the pandemic besides
powdering the balls with medicated gold
bonds nothing there was no moment where
you were like
because i feel like during the pandemic
either people that were estranged kind
of yeah we fell in love in a way yeah
and then a lot of people that were in
love were like okay i loved you before i
was spending 24 7 with you for a year i
mean when he did like when he did get
covered i was kind of like oh my god i'm
gonna have so much time to myself now
this is fucking toy
um so i i watch amelie and perry okay um
by the way that's how you're supposed to
say it family oh yes well yes you're
supposed to say amelie and perry well
emily
emily and paris doesn't run yeah amelia
and perry i have to know what phil
collins daughter is up to you the fact
that okay can we talk about some
celebrity some people that we didn't
know were related sometimes when people
tell me people that are related it blows
my mind to the point where i need to
like take a walk and question everything
did you know l king the singer is rob
schneider's daughter yeah yeah
i didn't know that yeah and perry was
phil collins daughter until like three
months ago i'm i'm up to speed i had to
cancel like four meetings yes
and you know did you know that um uh
nicholas cage is related to francis ford
coppola yeah yeah
what how am i missing all of this
what i'm i gotta get off infowars isn't
that wild that she's that that she's i
don't know what pat jason schwartzman's
a coppola also jason schwartzman is a
coppola yeah nick cage's cousin yes
like what a mind fuck
no one is stressed out about no i i used
to watch inside the actor's studio so i
knew like all these things oh yes oh he
got canceled huh well he died yeah
that's the ultimate formula yeah he died
he got cancelled by cancer cancer yeah
he died he died but i think he got right
before he died i think there was some no
no so like he used to he was a pimp for
a while like i think in paris uh-huh
i don't i know way too much about james
did you and perry get out of here lipton
she ordered tea the second she got in
she's like spill the tea on lipton
what's up with lipton can you start a
podcast called spilling the tea on james
lipton sponsored by lipton i'm just
saying i will have no subscribers
[Laughter]
but wait hold on maybe we should start
stealing his questions for this show
what's your favorite sound
oh
my favorites
i do like that i like people i like
typing oh really because i i type i i
don't uh i type all my books on my my
like just it just feels like product
soothing products it's just like nice it
can get like a rhythm going
yeah i like that it's okay what is your
favorite word oh wait what's your
favorite sound my favorite sound oh gosh
i like that cha-ching that venmo makes
you know that sound goes
um you know what's weird cause i feel
like on some level everyone that wanted
to be in this business we've like
practiced our inside the actors studio
in our head like the way we'd answer
these questions and i feel like i
practiced them and now my favorite sound
is
i like rain oh yeah it's raining that's
cute yeah i've got like the rain she
canceled a meeting on us to sit in the
rain
she said it's can we change the meeting
it's going to rain and we were like i
guess i mean again
you are financially stable
when you can check the weather and be
like meetings cancelled she's she's like
a she's like a like a hound she'll go
outside it's gonna rain
she's like sniffing the air i'm like
okay i love the rain so much i just i we
were no we were meeting at six on zoom
and i was like it's raining can we push
it to 6 30. so what did i say
i don't know grace said we'll just i
have to go to a movie
and then somebody's like i have to go to
a movie and she's like fine i guess
we'll meet at six no i wrote you have
the will to live we get it no response
um but then we ended up keeping it
because i did get stuck in the rain i
realized rain is an asshole yeah um i
like it when it's an app i like it when
it's the rain sound app i like that what
is your favorite word
fetus
i have a favorite curse word like fuck
yes that's my favorite curse work but
regular word
oh
i don't know what do people normally
answer my favorite christmas
bitch yeah i love it when you're sort of
a bitch
yeah that's my favorite my mom's son of
a bitch um that's a great one uh i like
idiot
idiot like it's just such i say it to
myself more like something stupid
happens it's like an idiot it's just
like the way that it hits what is your
least favorite word
lee's favorite word is
this are so weird can it be a phrase yes
um
i mean he's dead so yeah
i think we do whatever you want um
bumping this back to the top of your
inbox
it's like
it didn't need to be at the top my least
favorite is per my last email
my boyfriend loves to drop that i
literally just just let chime in bacon
oh look i think you'll find per my last
email that's one of my favorites so
condescending
in the parking lot let's just
like fight like adults why are we like
pretending
wait can i ask you a weird question pat
oh oh i was like where are the cameras
i literally
i just had the weirdest moment because
these have teleprompters in them now and
i was like there's one camera and it's
not pointing to us i was like
i was like we just have to keep going
and i'm just gonna have to lie to her
about
the valley's favorite phrase when
someone goes you know what i mean yeah i
just heard you everything
okay well that you're attacking me
that's you know what i mean i say that a
lot i think no i never noticed really i
can't stand when someone gives the whole
thing you know what i mean yeah i know
listen to the whole thing but you know
what they mean
i do you know what they mean
because you probably didn't respond to
them and they're like can you please say
something back you're probably looking
at them like and they're like do you
know what i mean
say something
i just think it's so weird yeah because
you make people scared so they're like
what i mean no
but okay tell it again but you but that
you know
this is this is
someone's being rhetorical well you know
what perma last name is i mean stop
asking the same fucking question okay
read the email i already spent okay guys
we can listen to you in bet and fight
anytime so can we talk to phoebe please
wow don't you have some burps to do
i did
write a whole list of things that i want
to talk to you about because let's do it
as an expert on all things trash
and uh don't sit on my bed in your
outside clothes this is i mean no one is
more genius at titles than phoebe
robinson thanks nobody
nobody
and this made me think about
the fact the first day that i learned
that guys don't wash their jeans
do you know what i'm saying menotriflin
in general yeah just but not washing the
jeans are you washing your jeans bake
off of course but i do know somebody
that puts them in the freezer yes yeah
but that's actually supposed to be
better because it kills the bacteria i
don't do that but i heard that that is
actually better than watching them
thoughts on someone coming up and saying
can i hug you
yeah i appreciate that you know what
yeah but can you say no
yeah it's like fans what can i hug you
and you're like yeah i'll be like no i
think about you these are the things i
think about you i'm like ww yeah prd
what would phoebe do like is this a
trash move or not hard boiled eggs on a
plane
no
i had to do you do that i know i had an
experienced research session no but i
did last time you're on i told you about
how sometimes i stick gum into the
magazines yeah i was like this bitch
you're disgusting
people who are sick at work just go home
as someone that runs a business do you
want someone who's sick to be there
sorry i'm getting better
just go home yeah i just feel like as an
employee you know the reason why people
go in is because their employers are
assholes and they feel scared that they
can't take time off that's true so i'm
always like guys if you are sick truly
take the time off i'm not going to like
think anything
untoward about you and you've got to use
your six days which are also your
vacation days right right right right
right okay so the key to that is to make
sure people have more time off
um
when people pick food out of their teeth
yeah while they're talking to you yeah
look at it
and then eat it
i do that in private now
you can do that when you see someone do
this look at it that's disgusting i will
leave the premises
it is you know what i'm talking about
when someone doesn't know you're talking
to them you haven't seen people do oh
people no
oh my god this and then they'll like
look at it because i think they do it in
private and then they accidentally do it
in public
it makes me so physically ill it's
disgusting um
okay when someone is putting their hair
up this is mostly the
the emily's of the world yeah
with a long once the white girl is doing
a top notch and then they do this and
they pull hairs out
and then
i was working with an editor
really who was in front of me and she
would do this with her hair pull the
hairs that were loose out there like
three or four and then just drop it on
the floor where would you like us to put
them yeah
keep collecting a wig for you
in the toilet or in the toilet while
she's editing you wanted her to get up
every time do you know how long that
would have taken a trash can so she's
the first floor yeah it's probably it's
probably a nervous thing you should see
my car floor you should see the floor of
my car that makes me physically ill
maybe this is why you're sick all the
time because you're eating your own hair
you have a hair ball in your throat
maybe that's why
people like like to pull their hair
ticket yeah but you can't put the hair
from your head let's go on the floor who
gives a shit
your curling iron is on the fucking
you're fucking clear all right curly
hair look there's no one don't touch it
it's not hot
that's
i do not believe you should pull the
hair out of your head and then put it on
a communal floor well then don't come
over here
that is
disgusting whitney is just hair but when
he didn't like hair she really hates wet
hair
in the shower
there's a girlfriend of mine who it
fucked up our relationship because um
she came to my house and she stayed for
a little while and
her hair would get on the shower wall
and she would like make swirlies with it
and
leave it on the shower that's ignorant
yeah it was the most blair witch shit
i'd ever seen
and i was like is this your hair and
she's like oh yeah like jumping again
and i was like yeah i want you to
fucking get it
that's a big trend on tick tock to draw
a picture of your hair
but to be fair whitney also uses her
hair as floss
i do use my hair is dental floss
they say one goddamn thing by the way
when i'm in a jam because i don't use my
finger like an animal but sometimes when
you use your hair's dental floss
sometimes it gets stuck and you'll have
like one haircut
in my life
i have never
sometimes i'm in a jam sometimes i'll
use the corner of an envelope but if i
don't have that just get some oral b
flossers no but we're on the road
sometimes the cities i go to because
i've got i i've got these tax bills uh
they don't have floss sometimes you know
um okay how oh escape rooms do i am i an
asshole for not want to do escape rooms
it's supposed to be like a fun bonding
experience
hanging out with people you get to see
people's true personalities i don't want
anyone to see my true personality well
jeremy to show you how she reacts i'll
be when you ask me to go to escape room
do you want to go to an escape room are
you fucking stupid like no are you are
you
are you serious why would you want to be
it's fine
why would i want to be like a spooky
room i can't get it because it's fake
like if you're like you're sick of it
you could like let us out please and
i'll let you out i auditioned for white
men in hollywood for 15 years in hotel
rooms
for the rest of my life you're exempt
you're really good at this i want to go
with you
i just sit there and cry and start doing
a monologue
um people oh hoodies hoodies oh you're
wearing shirts okay but this is for you
why are you wearing a hoodie that says
melanin this is you isn't this yours no
no but you talked to people i would not
sit a white one with a hoodie that says
melanin on it get your goofy ass out of
here it's your hoodie bert no bitch you
did not sell this on your podcast no you
did not talk about this on your podcast
i talk about melanin but i did not put
it on there
did she not do an episode where she
talked about these hoodies
no
okay i okay now i'm past me now i'm
pissed okay i
am hold on let me go to the last episode
of whatever you were talking about these
hoodies and the money was like going to
charity so i was like why don't i wear
it so people will buy it actually she
might be right there but what was
hold on the last ep it was an episode of
black frasier
and you guys were talking about these
hoodies so i was like oh i got one right
no you had a melanin mug that's a
melanin mug here's what i will say and
then i was like i'll wear it so that
people buy it because it's hurt why are
they letting me wear that
thing
out of this episode no i didn't i don't
want white people to buy anything that
says melanin on it
don't
get we'll give them your money to share
donate money to howard university white
lady
donate your teeth money to howard
university
to pay for tonight's ecosystem salary by
the way this is this is
oh my god i didn't even realize it said
that
look i am doing my work as an ally i'm
willing to be humiliated but we talked
about it didn't we howard university.edu
probably
donate
uh i will sell my teeth by the way if
you think i have teeth money kesha came
on with a necklace full of her fans
teeth so we won't let you see that
episode okay i i'm going to take this
hoodie i don't think you should you
don't wear it you said this this whole
time when you're in this honeymoon
we're starting over so phoebe phoebe's
here today you guys this is cute though
okay i'm gonna take it she definitely
said buy this why would i have it
why would i have that
why would i have you've just been
watching me wear this what do you just
thought i thought it was cool i didn't
realize it until you're like so this
sweatshirt i'm like this just says
melanin on it
i bought it because of you
this was me trying to do i mean we're
learning this entire
you episode i would send you a shirt
that said melody crazy no you talked
about this you were like
it's a black owned brand that says
melanin like it the proceeds go to
something so i just bought it
your fans when they're watching this are
gonna go oh that's the thing i should
donate to that thing god damn it that's
gonna be like what is this white lady
i thought it's a
melon
no i cannot believe you did not did no
it's from an episode of black fraser
where else would i have i apprec i
appreciate like your heart i i'm glad
you you you spent that money
but you can't wear this
it was only for never worn it before
i'm sweating
i i kept away on that i don't even
like because i thought it was going to
get people to buy it and drive money to
this thing look i'm sweating there
should be a different tab for white
people just to donate yeah it's so hot
no because i was there disclaimer yeah i
saw some so a white person like had
there's this company called all black
everything yeah yeah so if you're if you
if you are not
i used i buy i i did buy the hoodie set
and give it to brandon goodman right
great that is the correct move but i do
not want to see you wearing black
everything
now okay
no
not the all black like the color black
that's a different one
it's a great website but they also have
cosmetics they have lots of stuff
yeah and uh yes we got the all black
everything we got a bunch of the hoodies
and the sweatpants and only gave it to
guests of color
yeah cosmetics are a great way for white
people yes yes exactly i mean it looks
the hoodie looks really cute on me but
i'm not gonna
have you worn this in front of your
boyfriend and did he say anything i
haven't worn it at all i saved it for
when you were coming on because the
guest is coming on oh we have to get all
their stuff and have it all ready and i
was like look at me i've got i'm going
to be wearing a hoodie because she's got
something fucking out this is by the way
this is almost like as bad as when
chelsea lynn came on the show and she
was wearing a marilyn manson shirt two
days after like all the alley and she
didn't know
and i was like and benton had not come
in yet because benton just calls it like
he sees it and i was like you know i
don't want to be the dick who's like hey
you i can't tell the change she drove
all the way up here from san diego like
maybe she didn't have another shirt to
wear yeah and then we're talking and
it's literally just marilyn manson's
face and benny white and betty white and
then benton comes and sits down and she
goes is that a marilyn manson shirt and
she's like yeah oh no
she's like i'm thinking am i getting
canceled she's like i'm getting
cancelled
[Applause]
this i can't believe you don't remember
this
i'm going to find the episode it was i'm
sure i said it
i should have been clearer
she should have said please buy this
money not whitney
hi we're taking another break from
whitney and phoebe having a hilarious
conversation for us to talk about some
of our best friends best fiends listen
i've been playing this game
so much more than everybody else i'm
winning basically
and i am obsessed my little brain is
stronger than ever that you won't even
talk to me like
in airports you're like playing
you'll
you won't hang out with your best friend
you'll play best fiend because i'm
trying to evolve my fiends okay the bugs
the bugs
and the slugs i want there to be a
praying mantis yeah i don't know what
what bug you would be i've been thinking
about this a lot slugs are the slu songs
are evil they're always like such like
cute but like i mean i love i'm a bug
person i just like bugs so you be a
prank mantis
okay and you dress accordingly praying
mantises after they made yeah they bite
that head on off their
partner and i i my mouth is i'm a
romantic people think it's big what
would you be
um a new one oh a new bug i just really
i don't want to know you're not god you
like the ladybug you're you are a
ladybug i love the ladybug you know what
in my freshman year of college my
roommate and i hated each other and she
would collect ladybugs and put them on
my pillow and i was like joke's on you i
like ladybugs this is a theme so what
mental institutions did you go to school
in let me girl interrupt you for a
second uh you interrupt us okay go ahead
girl interrupted they stole that title
from me yesterday i should sue them for
a copyright infringement but best fiends
when i'm stressed out playing best means
is kind of like it helps me like i love
it it jolts your brain it does it helps
you like cleanse your brain from the
toxic stuff
it's like the perfect amount of engaging
it's not like
like stressful engaging it's just like
it's relaxing that's what it is it is
relaxing what scene would i be you ask
oh
that's cute you wouldn't be a yellow
jacket
no because do you call them i call them
potato butter yellow chicken well that's
dumb um
roly-poly we call them roly-poly
why they're roly-poly potato potato oh
because they'll eat potatoes you're
irish it's irish ancestry
a roly-poly is a great one because i
could be like i'm over it
that's what that's what you do in real
life
roly-polies are awesome i mean i don't
think best fiends is is currently taking
pictures from us uh there it's one of
the biggest games uh on the planet
that's one of the best things about best
fiends is that you never get bored
because there's new content being
uploaded constantly yes and you're not
just playing you're not just matching
items you're not just matching like you
know whatever together there's a
storyline you're there's a story you're
playing you're going through different
levels there's a whole story you're
following an arc so you're actually you
know you're like growing with your boss
so always something new download best
fiends free today on the app store or
google play that's friends without the r
best fiends thanks four eyes
[Music]
[Laughter]
she got herself she was so ready to do
that
she was sitting there she was sitting
and now
we're gonna talk about my favorite topic
on the planet
me
making money in your sleep
the best relatable
the best thing
you can do for you we talk a lot about a
positive investments in your future self
right right don't send that text to that
exit two in the morning because your
next day you're gonna be embarrassed
you're gonna hate yourself you're gonna
be waiting right like what's a positive
contribution to your future self always
always always what i do understand is
that if you invest you are going to and
if you're like smart about it right
basically invest in in companies or
products that you believe in that you
would buy yourself right rubies
will
get your investment back
big big time so public is making this
accessible to actual human beings public
has taken that
thing of like you have to like be in a
social circle or know a bunch of or have
a business manager i don't have a
business manager my business manager is
my dad you know what i mean
exactly
some like creepy wall street people yeah
you know what i'm saying it's like i
don't want to have to you don't have to
be a millionaire to invest you know i
don't you don't have to be friends with
jeffrey epstein just to invest connect
with investors from all walks of life to
learn new ideas and gain confidence
choose from thousands of stocks and etfs
along with 10 popular cryptocurrency and
get exclusive access to growing
community full of feller i'm sorry
investors
full of them failure and i invested my
time in corn and potatoes and donkeys
and i'm going to take them down to the
tractor pool i'm going to invest
after i invest in public you will get
exclusive access to a growing community
of fellow investors
start investing with as little as one
dollar
and get a free slice of stock up to
fifty dollars when you join public.com
today fifty dollars can turn into a lot
of money over time fifty dollars that's
eight radishes
at the farmer's market in la house
visit public.com whitney to download the
app and sign up that's public.com
whitney what do you want to invest in
emily
myself
okay no somebody's gonna make money
i'm investing my time to get into your
will
that's smart very smart there's only so
much room you're gonna have to become
one of my dogs if you want to get the
real money uh yeah i know i um what do i
want to invest in you know i got i got
to look on public because i don't know
yeah i mean interesting i don't know
what's coming down the pipe that's why
publix is good because lawyers don't
bring me anything except restraining
orders from ex-boyfriends so um
so public is good because you can go on
there and it's a community like you can
talk to people you don't have to be a
businesswoman but you can have these
conversations yeah and they're really
interesting we love you guys
do it invest in good for you and use
this valid for u.s residents 18 and over
subject to account approval see
public.com disclosures not investment
advice oh my god i can't even use it
because i'm only 17.
back to my friend phoebe robinson
[Music]
i would never dress just in a hoodie
from you on the show i was like i'm
going to wear her she has a partnership
with this hoodie
okay well look it's fine we've we got
through it we'll get you one that says
has none
and then you can wear that
yeah
i'm going to send that to robin d'angelo
um
oh my god how's she doing these days you
know what she's she's
uh feels guilty i think
from what i understand yeah yeah yeah
feels terrible about all that feels
terrible yeah
i mean it really is a it's a look at
someone that bought the book
and then realize later
wrong books when you read it were you
just like yes or were you like cause
like when i read it i was like
yeah i think when you first read it
because she spends so much time
saying
uh this is the book white fragility she
spent so much time being like
time to have the uncomfortable
conversations eyes like she is so like i
had internalized racism and i didn't
even know and like
like it's it for a second comes off so
like oh you're willing to admit all
these embarrassing things about yourself
so it's kind of like
there's but then you kind of are like oh
you're just kind of making money off of
yeah yeah so you shouldn't be keeping
the money you shouldn't be keeping the
money completely
and you shouldn't be the face told you
you had it and where's their point of
view yeah
yeah
this to you because it also took me a
while to realize like oh this is
she's like i go and lecture to rich
white people about how we're rich and
white yeah and like
it's just a cycle they just stay in it
yes nothing changes in a way it's almost
like okay the box is checked of like i
did my work i read this book
yes and i read this really uncomfortable
book and i faced all these things but
it's all right well that's done yeah
it's almost like a false sense of
progress and a false sense of awareness
and you're like but i just read this
book i just did my work it's like no
i highlighted pages you're like okay
okay okay cute
um i put melanin on my pages um okay
well
look what
have you learned about running a company
she said to be more clear
to be way more direct
about the dress code of the employees
white people would buy anything
i i because i ordered it i was like i
can't post about it and that's being
performed yes
maybe i'll give it and then i was like
oh phoebe's coming on the show i'll just
wear it on the show
so the people will buy it you will love
this
oh
gosh
i by the way you saw me looking for i
was like should i wear this oh yeah she
was hunting for it she changed three
times so cute look at how much i'm
sweating oh i was keeping a hoodie on i
didn't even want to wear because i was
so hot that's sweet because i thought it
was your merch
so i cannot wait to get to know you as a
friend and know what is your merch and
what is not whoever's company i just
helped out i hope it's not sean king
yes you guys know sean king said i
should wear it yes you're like
okay the most problematic person all
right what do they call them talcomax
okay what i've learned about uh right
now right now that you're running a
business like being a boss
i think
i
am more compassionate and i think you
know because you have to like
yes you want people to like show up and
be their best selves for work but you
also have to be compassionate about
everyone's like going through something
and being there being present and sort
of just kind of the interpersonal
relationships i think that's what i
really had to learn because for so long
it was just like either me or it was
just me and my and so
just her and i just against the world
but now there's more people involved so
i really need to make sure everyone
feels seen and heard yes and also like
acknowledging that other people have
emotions and bad days and aren't always
going to be super high energy and
chipper but not
uh but still having boundaries
oh i don't need to know too much about
you like we're not going to be besties
at work yeah but i still acknowledge
that you are a human being yeah and like
finding that balance yeah yeah great
that's the hardest thing i think about
hiring because it's like you want to
hire the person you get along with have
chemistry with but it's also like uh if
i like you too much this is probably
gonna get weird yeah yeah yeah for sure
um and then uh i mean i wrote so many
questions out uh but look i'm just gonna
just pick whatever this has been so this
is here's the thing like
it's good to just like sort of key key
and have fun because people listening to
this are hearing how much fun we're
having yes yes 100 so you don't have to
like stick to the question yeah it's so
funny because you were like the third
episode of the podcast yeah and i still
have no idea what i'm doing yeah i'm
still like what is the podcast supposed
to be am i supposed to be asking
questions i was like no one's gonna
listen to this episode because they
don't know who i am no that's not true
that is what i said after we tab was
like no one's gonna listen but people i
i i think i'm yes you've had what four
podcasts now
i think yeah just there or something are
you gonna keep doing them
uh i want to keep doing black frasier of
like all of them i want to keep doing
that but of don't buy anything she tells
you to buy on there
just don't listen to anything she says
or it'll blow up in your face but i want
it's all dependent on his schedule
because he does it with you yeah it's so
fun to listen to it's like it's just so
um it doesn't feel rushed it's there's
not like uh uh you're just so good at
podcasting at this point that there's
that it just feels like you're hanging
out with you it's like the best version
of it you know like i feel like when you
start a podcast you know you get the
most eyeballs when you're the least
good at it when you have the least
amount of practice you know it's like i
feel like i had to like learn in public
yeah but um black fraser is just it's so
and then you guys banter is like so good
and so soothing i mean it kind of pisses
me off because i'm like what is this
what relationships are supposed to be
like
like no one's snapping at each other
there's no like passive aggressive digs
you're like well if you had made me come
last night maybe i wouldn't be tired
like there's no
nastiness
so
listen to it is that a thing you've said
in the past
because that just came came out real
quick i can only come if i'm wearing a
melanin hoodie that's
um okay so special is out
phoebe robinson sorry harriet tubman you
guys are going to love it watch it post
about it so good so funny so funny it is
so funny i i am proud of it and it also
makes me go like okay i want to get like
elevate as a comic but i think this is a
very
good solid first special i i'm so happy
i was able to watch it in your melanin
hoodie
and look i and i just feel the need to
say this because i think a lot of
comedians right now think the way to be
relevant is to like lecture people how
to vote and how to think and like i have
to have this serious moment where i'm
vulnerable it is just like the perfect
comedy special you will
come away
thinking about things you never thought
about before like what to do with all
the money that's being spent on movies
about slavery like you know just like
the smartest most interesting take but
not like feeling like you're being
lectured to yeah i didn't want that i
want people to like laugh i don't want
people
me to be like here's how you can be woke
like that's not that's not what a santa
special is and it's not your job yeah
you teach people yeah you're also not a
teacher you didn't sign up for that you
signed up to make people laugh but
exactly but i do think that's like uh
just coincidentally the best way to get
through to people yeah they're like okay
i don't i'm not defensive about this but
that is such a fucking good point why
are we spending all this money on these
black trauma movies instead of just
giving them the money yeah it's just
it's just so smart so
um
uh
thought provoking um it made me jealous
that's that's the way i can endorse the
special the most it just it just made me
jealous how about that maybe you want to
work harder um your book please don't
sit on my bed in your outside clothes
it's out now
and you're just like swamped with press
how much more do you have to do uh like
a couple more weeks and then i'm gonna
just like focus on writing start start
the writer's room and so i'm just kind
of like it's really happening i'm so
excited for you ah
it's been so long
first of all for me trying to get my own
show
so i'm just sort of like i just want to
appreciate every moment
and just sort of
be good at it yeah you know what i mean
yeah yeah and just yeah and um like have
the most fun it just feels like you know
shows like romney like shows that our
friends are doing what it was kind of
like i think that because they maybe got
them a couple years after they deserved
it you're like i'm gonna do this my way
yeah because
i'm finally getting it and it could be
taken away at any moment so i at least
want to go down knowing i made the show
i want to make yes and that's when the
show ends up being so good that it's
going to stay on yeah you know fingers
crossed yeah it's just like trusting
your gut on it yeah oh thanks with i'm
so
jealous of you
yeah you're such a good like example of
like being happy and in the moment and
like doing what you want to do and
instead of having to preach you're so
good about like living the way you want
to live and that being the example
instead of like telling us what to do
thanks i just try because i just
i think nobody wants to be told like how
to live and it's just like we all have
to figure out let's like what's the one
way that we could like do something
that's going to help someone else you
know yeah yeah like when you figure that
out for yourself it just makes things so
much easier yeah that's kind of how i
try to go about it and i just feel like
so many people who are like activists
now mike the only thing that's changing
is like your brand so it's not actually
activism you don't even yeah it's just
your profile you're just so easy to be
like happy for you're so easy to be like
really
oh thank you we're obsessed with you i'm
obsessed with you guys i love seeing you
on the road
are you gonna are you getting ready to
take an hour
is that why you're touring like crazy
hard yeah i think i'm going to shoot a
special like by the end of the year
um okay i want to come to the taping
yeah me like i'm just it's like the kind
of thing where it's like i'm
i'm i feel like it's it's not done but
we never feel like it's done it's never
i'm calling you the day of my last
special is this funny and then like yeah
the day of the special i'm like oh i
have two new bits and i'm like oh fuck
all right you know that's what happens
because your mind is gets the most
creative when you're about to like do
something else totally and then you're
in post and you think of the perfect tag
and you're like yeah but it's fine we
can talk about it on podcasts and we can
like you know yeah like always be adding
and adding and adding but i do think the
days of like
you know an hour like i think about
doing hbo because there's like there's a
lot of people are watching hbo max it's
like
emily and perry yeah and um
perry's next what are you going to call
that flea what are you going to call
this special a little miss melanin i
don't know
too dark for this clothes
the sun's not my problem
i'm gonna call it pigment deep pigment
rachel dolezal's dude
she's your opener
she's doing the hair makeup because i
want to make sure i want to make sure
it's perfect and i'm going to shoot it
at howard university
we're going to share it on peace
um and uh i just don't want to burn the
wrong bridge yeah um
what a nightmare
no thank you for having me on i love you
so much i love you too and i you know
we're always like working and grinding
and so i just want you to enjoy your new
house
with all the renovations and your
beautiful life and your beautiful teeth
and just like
surely like you're always working i
really just want you to also take a
timeout and look at the life that you
built for yourself and be really fucking
proud that you did that oh man i love
you i love you too and ditto and i hope
that um you just have the most fun on
your show thanks cause that's that's it
it's like jokes at the end of the day
don't matter start like it's like it's
just like your energy on the show this
is something i did not learn making a
show because i was like
so by the time you got into act i was
like okay we go and get it was that like
yeah the first day i shot i was really
kind of stressed and nervous well in
part in part because the first scene we
had to shoot was a sex scene so it was
very it's like a jokey sex scene but i
was so nervous about it but after that i
was just like
because i kept being like what's that
okay am i doing okay blah blah and then
is that not what everyone does during
sex yeah
so you mean just like and then when i
went home that night after i shot the
first day and i was like
you're chewing your head like if you're
shading the bed someone will like the
show runner will pull me aside and be
like phoebe's like get it together so i
was like i'm just gonna have fun yeah
i'm gonna show up on time
have make people laugh and then like go
home and like everyone had a good time
you can't fail at that point yeah it's
already been written you've hired the
most talented people you're you it can't
go wrong the only thing that can go
wrong is you not being in the moment
yeah exactly it's like i have my acting
coach all like i did all those things so
i was like just kind of think of all the
shitty shows that have been really
successful yeah
and
and then think oh this show is good
imagine you know what i mean yeah i
don't have to worry yeah if you if you
do half
what of what you wanted to accomplish
it's still going to be twice as good as
most things
she knows because of her show dear white
people
we have to let phoebe go phoebe where do
you want to send your teeth
what's the address for your teeth
i've made it
awesome i love you i love you too phoebe
robinson uh if you're not following on
instagram you are a silly goose
because the thursdays are especially um
delicious um and uh and um yeah new
special new show on freeform that's
coming out soon book is out now
follower give her money
don't buy the hoodie or buy it just
don't wear it yeah
wouldn't you tell me to grab your cocoa
butter okay you know what can i tell you
something i'm not i'm not this is excuse
me this i wanted to hide instantly
donald rawlings has his lotion line oh
that's funny and yeah and i had this
here it's called the i'm rich ultra rich
body butter and i i i knew it was right
here that's no that's good because i
feel like white people don't lotion
enough because they're like we don't get
ashy i'm like yeah you fucking do yeah
we do so you're great you go yeah we do
yeah it's just that we leave our dead
sea you're like peeling everywhere i'm
not crazy i'm like what the fuck
yes this is uh uh that is donelle's
cocoa butter brand
it's
great great lotion
um i love you guys phoebe robinson
we love her so much next time we are
going to con you into doing this again
um because i don't have as much money as
you think so i still will be doing this
um uh we will have her longer hopefully
love you guys don't write elephants
phoebe
adrian max right now
don't be silly
[Music]
[Applause]